a lot of people including myself were
saying that r
may have been on a bit of a downturn
over the last couple years
but were we maybe a little bit too quick
to pass judgment
keep watching and we'll discuss this i'm
richard and this is richard on data
all right so just a little over six
months ago i did a video comparing
r and python in the year 2020 so i do
highly recommend watching that video
before
this one if you haven't already because
i do talk about things like the learning
curve and the capabilities of these two
languages
and by and large all those comparisons
are true today too
but i did also compare the popularity of
these two languages
and i looked at a few pieces of
information indicating that the tide of
popularity
could slowly be turning against r so in
particular
i looked at the tyobi index and i
pointed out that in january of 2019
r was number 12 on that index and by
january of 2020
r had fallen all the way to number 18.
for those of you who are totally
unfamiliar with the tyobi index
it's a pretty well-known and commonly
used indicator of various programming
languages popularity
and it's all based on relative search
hits
from things like google wikipedia bing
etc etc etc that wasn't the only
indication of that
i also pointed out this kd nuggets poll
that was done last year
and this was a survey they did of 1800
programmers
asking what technology they often use
for analytics data science and machine
learning and in two years
r fell from 56.6 percent to 46.6 percent
so a drop of exactly 10 percent all
while python was rising
python went from 59 to 65.8 percent
in the same time period katy nuggets
also put this together
so they track data science jobs listed
on indeed between the years 2017 and
2019
and they looked at how many of them
mentioned the various different
languages out there
and they did also mention that r did
experience an
up growth over time but it was getting
absolutely
dwarfed by python so when we look at the
entire time period here
there were nearly thirty thousand jobs
listing python
then just over twenty five thousand jobs
listing sql
but it looks like under fifteen thousand
jobs listed
are sad so that's where we stood at the
beginning of this year
but there's some indication out there
that the trends against
r are beginning to reverse themselves in
particular the thing that a lot of
people are noticing now
is that in the tyobi index r's position
has
absolutely skyrocketed so if you look at
the graph of the tyobi index for
r over time notice at the beginning of
this year
right when 2020 begins r's share of
overall
search volume had fallen quite a bit to
under one percent of all programming
languages searches
but now it has absolutely surged to an
all-time high
and not only that if you look at the top
r is the number eight
programming language of all time and
this is literally the highest ranking it
has ever held in the tyobi index
all of this might just indicate that
something might be going on here
so let's dive into this a little bit
further before i do that just some asks
number one please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
i do notice that a lot of my view volume
comes from people who haven't subscribed
to my channel
so please do that also smash the like
button to this video because that
really does help my content reach a
larger audience
also i do have a link in the description
of this video to my patreon account
if you guys are willing to support me
there that would be massively
appreciated
so the tyobi index is not the only
metric that's been done
indicating that r might be on the rise
let's turn our attention to the analysis
firm
redmonk because they've created their
own index for this kind of thing
now their index is based i think on pull
requests from
github as well as mentions on stack
overflow
and there's a lot going on on this graph
but here if you just look at the left
side notice you've got r starting in the
number 17 spot
all the way back in 2012 and while it's
not at an all-time high here
it's risen to the number 13 spot now
that we're into 2020.
note that the cutoff point of this
analysis was june 2020
here so it's a little bit earlier than
the tyobi index is cut off
which is all the way up to august of
2020. now i think it's fair to point out
that these things are not perfect
measures of popularity
and in fact they do suffer from their
own certain types of biases
in particular redmonk is measuring
activity from github and stack overflow
and i think it's pretty fair to assume
people from those two communities
tend to be experienced developers and
programming enthusiasts
so you're kind of leaving out people who
are less experienced or they're
newcomers to these languages
who are certainly still using them but
they're a little bit shyer to share
their code on there
as for the tyobi index you may have some
bias there
in favor of more difficult languages as
well as the languages that's a little
bit more difficult to google stuff for
so you have to do multiple queries in
particular i know with
r there's a lot of people who have a
little bit of difficulty getting into it
particularly if you come from a computer
science rather than a statistics
background
so these are all valid points against
these indices
so let's look at what's going on in the
industry well you've seen this graph
already if you've seen my video
reviewing anaconda's state of data
science reports
but they found that r was the second
most popular language in the data
science community
out of all of the languages they
surveyed that is
and this is based on a sample size of
1592
and it's across a variety of industries
as well as academia
and to be fair r is a very distant
second
to python but it's still got 47
of respondents saying they sometimes to
always use it compare that with python
which has
91 percent of respondents saying the
same but still
i haven't been able to find any updates
on the job market that have been done in
the last couple months
however in the past it's generally been
the case
that r enjoys a lot of preference in
research and academic environments
as well as in the health care industry
now there have been a couple theories
floated about r's
increase in popularity over this time
period and these theories come
courtesy of the tyobi ceo paul jansen
so let's discuss both of these and then
i have my own theory
his first theory is that technologies
like sas
and stata and spss are done
and the increase in r's popularity comes
at the downfall of those technologies
and that's certainly a believable and
predictable turn of events
there are just more and more
organizations out there that are
beginning to realize the value of open
source programming
and there are certain industries for
which sas is a little bit sticky
but even that is beginning to diminish a
little bit
his other theory which i have seen
floated in some other circles
is that all of this is due to the
disease that's been making its way
around the globe throughout this year
obviously the healthcare and
pharmaceutical industries need to do a
lot of data analysis
so that we get a vaccine developed this
year
but even independently there's been so
much
data analysis and hackathons and
dashboards and visualizations of this
disease
that have occurred at least i've begun
to notice them since march of this year
so the theory is because there's been so
much of this activity
it's given r a bit of a temporary boost
now i'm a little bit less sold on this
theory than the other one
because the number of independent
analyses out there has gone down
quite a bit since march and april when
the disease was at its newest and it's
scariest to most people
but over the same period r has just
continued to grow
but just more broadly speaking though
when we start talking about
trends in industry as well as what
programming languages are beginning to
come
in and out of favor it is sort of
impossible
to divorce that from the pandemic and
the ensuing economic slowdown that's
happening around most parts of the world
right now
so the next question is how has the
pandemic
really affected data science jobs well
data scientist jobs have taken a beating
at least in the united states just like
the rest of the job market
and job postings for data scientists are
definitely way
down from the previous year although
some companies like google
amazon apple and such are definitely
taking advantage
and they've ramped hiring up now as you
guys probably all know by now
the data science field is really
dominated by those two languages
r and python however the broader tech
sector
outside of data science is much more
diverse
when you have people getting laid off
and they're interviewing for new jobs
and they're googling things
it's all over the place you've got
people using c
java javascript c plus plus c
sharp php i mean it's all over the place
whereas layoffs that occur in the data
science field
could get people who were previously
just exclusively python users
starting to take a second look at r
because they have to consider a new job
for which r is just part of what they
use
so this could be a possible reason why
you see r
experiencing a huge increase in
popularity while
other programming languages appear to be
roughly flat
so back to our original question is r
surging in popularity and honestly i do
think the evidence for this
at this time is pretty mixed i think the
tyobi index and things like that are
informative
but they do need to be taken with a
grain of salt as well as follow-up
analysis
and right now you simply can't separate
things like this
from the short-term realities that we're
facing because of the pandemic
and the economic slowdown that's
resulted once
those things are over we may know this
for sure
i also think it remains pretty clear
that python
is the leader of the data science world
right now
every survey that i've seen done in the
last several years
indicates that one thing we can take
away though
is that the people who were more
pessimistic and they were expecting
r's demise were not correct about that
again r is beloved in academia
in research in the healthcare and
pharmaceutical industries
not to mention people with statistics
backgrounds find it incredibly easy to
pick up
at least most of the time so it really
isn't going anywhere anytime soon
it's my preferred choice to this day
because of its visualization
capabilities
the notebooks it has as well as shiny
apps
so in the end if you're a current or
aspiring data scientist
i always recommend learning sql before
you learn
either r or python and then honestly
just pick one
r or python get really good at that one
it doesn't really matter which one you
pick so much as that you do
pick one of them and you get good at it
and
r remains a fantastic choice if you want
to go that route in 2020
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it smash the like button
also leave me a comment down below and
let me know what you think is going on
with r
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data